- When you hear the
title, "Bride of Chucky,"
the first thing you're
probably gonna think of
is "Bride of Frankenstein,"
the 1935 sequel to "Frankenstein,"
starring Boris Karloff.
That's the movie we see Tiffany watching
in the bathtub early on
in "Bride of Chucky."
- She's alive!
- If you haven't seen it,
there are some similarities.
Primarily, the main
message of "Frankenstein"
and "Bride of Frankenstein"
which is actually just told to us
at verbatim in the movie.
There's a character for Mary Shelley,
the author of the "Frankenstein" novel,
and she explains the moral of the story
before we jump into it.
- The punishment that befell a mortal man
who dared to emulate God.
- "Bride of Chucky"
explores similar territory.
Although it has no
opening were Don Mancini
just straight up tells the
audience what the movie is about,
it tells the story of Tiffany Valentine,
who collects the pieces of the Chucky doll
and stitches them back together
to try to bring back her
ex-boyfriend, Charles Lee Ray,
but ends up regretting it when
she's treated poorly by him.
I'm gonna talk about the
more specific homages
that "Bride of Chucky" paid
to "Bride of Frankenstein,"
but there is another horror
movie that, ironically,
probably influenced "Bride
of Chucky" way more.
To learn the significance
of Tiffany's nail file,
stick around to the end of this video.
(upbeat rock music)
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Back in 2019, I made a series of videos
on the "Child's Play" movies,
the first three movies
in the Chucky franchise.
So if you wanna watch those,
you can check out to this playlist.
And if you're already
watching that playlist,
now you know why I'm suddenly
significantly less awkward.
"Bride of Chucky" is a
sequel to "Child's Play 3,"
taking place no more than
a couple of months after.
It would be the first movie
not to feature series
protagonist Andy Barclay,
because they screwed
themselves in the third one
by recasting Andy with an older actor,
and now that actor is too old to play Andy
because the movie is set
while he's still a teen.
I mean, they could go
back to the original Andy
who is now the perfect age,
but then it would clearly
be two different people.
I think a lot of people
probably just wanted
to see Brad Dourif back as Chucky though,
and they would've gotten their wish.
Let's get in to The Things You Missed.
(sword zings)
(tense suspenseful music)
(air whooshing)
In both "Bride of Frankenstein"
and "Bride of Chucky,"
the revivals are triggered by electricity.
The voodoo spell used to bring back Chucky
involves a supernatural storm cloud
issuing a strike of lightning.
Then Chucky kills Tiffany by
electrocuting her in the bath
and uses the spell to transfer her soul
into another doll.
This time Chucky is
stitched together by hand
after Tiffany retrieved the pieces
that were torn apart in
the giant spinning fan
at the end of "Child's Play 3."
This gives him a similar look
to Frankenstein's monster
who is famously stitched
together by his creator.
In both movies,
the titular couples don't
end up getting along.
(classical tense music)
- [Monster] Friend?
(bride chuckles)
Friend?
(footsteps thudding)
(bride screams)
- But as I mentioned,
I don't think "Bride of Frankenstein"
was the biggest inspiration
for the fourth Chucky movie.
If you look at some of the marketing,
it becomes very clear
that Universal Pictures
was trying to capitalize on the success
of a more recent franchise,
as the official poster is a
direct parody of "Scream 2,"
and the logo with its pointy K
is basically rip off of the "Scream" logo.
"Scream" took the horror
world by storm in 1996,
thanks in part to its horror genre satire
and abundant self-awareness.
"Scream" is basically a slasher movie
that knows it's a slasher movie,
and "Scream 2" satirizes the cliches
of horror movie sequels.
The opening scene of "Scream"
references many horror movies
that came before it
in the iconic "Do you like
scary movies?" dialogue,
which includes references to "Halloween,"
"Nightmare on Elm Street,"
and "Friday the 13th."
The opening scene of "Bride of Chucky"
does a very similar thing.
We look inside the evidence room
at the Lockport Police Department,
where we see Michael Myers's
mask from "Halloween,"
Freddy Kruger's glove from
"Nightmare on Elm Street,"
and Jason's mask from "Friday the 13th."
This may also be Leatherface's chainsaw
from "The Texas Chainsaw Massacre."
A cop gathers up the remains of Chucky
and brings them to Tiffany,
who takes him out with
her sharp nail file,
which has this curved tip
that makes it look like
the knife used by Ghostface
in the "Scream" movies.
Additionally, there's a moment
during that opening scene of "Scream"
where the killer refers
to Casey as Blondie.
- [Ghostface] Can you
handle that? Blondie?
- Chucky's bride ends
up being a blonde woman
who's soul gets transferred
into a black haired-doll,
so she bleaches the hair back to blonde
while listening to Blondie.
The name of the Blondie song is "Call Me."
The killer in "Scream" intimidates victims
by calling them on the phone,
and Tiffany hires her neighbor
to transport the dolls in Bride
by calling him on the phone
so that he doesn't find out
that she's one of the dolls.
Shout out to this guy for
getting a couple of horror movies
into the top comments on the
music video for "Call Me."
As I mentioned, Scream's biggest gimmick
is that it's very self-aware.
Now, I don't want to spoil
it by showing the clip
in case there are people
that haven't seen "Scream,"
but if I did show the
clip, it would be this.
(tense foreboding music)
(air whooshing)
- Corn syrup.
Same stuff they use for
pig's blood in "Carrie."
- So it's important to note
that the first three "Child's Play" movies
weren't like that,
they were just like regular movies,
and now all the sudden after "Scream,"
Chucky has become very self-aware.
- In fact, if it was a movie,
it would take three or four
sequels just to do it justice.
- And there are all of these
horror movie references,
such as Chucky's head
spinning around 180 degrees
like the scene in "The Exorcist,"
the character Damien Blaylock
being a combination of
two characters' names
from "The Omen,"
Chucky telling Tiff to turn to page 217
in the "Voodoo For Dummies" book,
which is the same as
the haunted room number
in Stephen King's novel "The Shining,"
Jade asking David this question...
- David, do you remember when
you were seeing Brad Barker?
- Which seems to be a
combination of Brad Dourif,
who plays Chucky and Clive
Barker who created "Hellraiser."
"Hellraiser" is also referenced
after Chucky and Tiffany
take out Jade's uncle,
Chief Kincaid, by launching these nails
into his face using the van's airbag.
- Why does that look so familiar?
- That would be because
he now resembles Pinhead,
the iconic character in
the "Hellraiser" movies.
"Hellraiser" came out
a year before Charles
Lee Ray originally died,
so it might've been one of
the last movies he ever saw.
In fact, if we take a closer look
at this article about his death,
the newspaper reporter
includes an interview
with Mike Norris, the police
officer from "Child's Play."
He describes the scene
as being "like something
out of a horror movie."
There are some other
non-horror references,
like Tiffany's spider
being named Charlotte
and officer Norton referring
to Jesse as "Boogie Nights."
One of the mysteries
of the franchise so far
regards to the Haitian deity Damballa,
who Chucky calls upon
to give him the power
to transfer souls.
We've heard this Damballa
chant many times before,
but this time we see it in writing
inside of Tiffany's "Voodoo
For Dummies" manual.
That means that an English speaker
such as myself can properly
translate it for the first time.
(thunder clapping)
(tense suspenseful music)
The Damballa chant is a
French incantation meaning,
"To the almighty Damballa.
Give me the power I beg of you.
To the mercy of my soul.
To the point of my death.
Hear me out from my condemned voice."
Damballa is a Haitian entity,
and if you're unaware,
in Haiti, the official language is French,
so that's why the incantation
has to be in French.
There's actually a recurring
theme of French phrases
being used in the movie.
When Damien is cringefully
trying to seduce Tiffany
at the beginning,
he tells her about the French
saying "La Petite Mort,"
the little death, and
invites her onto the bed
to quote, unquote "die a little."
She asked him if he's
ready for a menage a trois,
which is French for threesome,
which is also a clue that
Chucky is actually alive,
but Damien doesn't quite get it.
- What's that?
- Finally, when Tiffany
confronts the thieving couple
at the love motel,
she throws a bottle of
champagne called Gout de Reims
or Taste of Reims,
which is the capital of the champagne
and wine growing region in France.
Now, if you would please draw
your attention to the boobs,
you'll notice that Tiffany has a tattoo
with Chucky's name on it,
and the heart is getting
stabbed by this little dagger.
She actually transfers this
tattoo to her doll body
after her soul is transferred,
during the scene where she dyes her hair
and gives the doll a makeover
to look more like her.
I don't know what the point
of going through all that was,
because she's planning
on transferring back
into a human body, like
within the next 24 hours.
Seems like a lot of wasted effort.
But I think the tattoo shows
that losing Chucky in the
1980s broke her heart,
but I also find it interesting
because in the first movie,
that's how you defeat Chucky,
Norris shoots him through the heart,
because his organs have turned human.
However, Bride gives new meaning to rules
from the first movie,
where John Bishop told them
they had to destroy the heart.
Maybe he didn't mean
that they had to shoot
Chucky in the heart,
because that obviously only
puts them down temporarily,
maybe he meant that they
needed to destroy this amulet,
The Heart of Damballa.
I don't quite get why they feel the need
to retrieve the amulet though,
because Chucky never attempts
to get it in the first
three "Child's Play" movies,
and there is a later movie
where he takes over a human body
without the amulet.
So...
I don't know. I don't have
an answer on this one.
But on the way to retrieve it,
Chucky and Tiffany cause
mayhem all around them,
taking out several police
officers and other bystanders,
causing their chauffeurs, the
young couple Jessie and Jade,
to look very guilty
as death follows them
everywhere that they go.
As they drive through the night,
we hear one other song
that I wanna talk about,
"See You In Hell" by Monster Magnet.
This song contains the following lyrics:
"What time and snow couldn't bury
Years of forgotten guilt.
That little body's calling, rising up
from under a Jersey landfill."
Well, it isn't a landfill,
but they're traveling to New Jersey
where the body of Charles
Lee Ray would rise up
from underground when
his skeleton is exhumed
to double-check that he's really dead
because Chucky's been leaving
Charles Lee Ray fingerprints
behind at all the crime scenes.
There's also the title
of the song to consider,
"See You In Hell."
Last episode, I talked
about how Chucky falling
into the pit in The
Devil's Lair dark ride,
symbolized him descending down into hell,
so the title foreshadows
this parting line in Bride:
- [Tiffany] Goobye, Darling.
I'll see you in hell.
(Chucky exhales sharply)
- Chucky is able to
finish Tiffany off though,
so it ends up being Jesse
who shovel-yeets him
into his own casket, where
he starts freaking out.
(dramatic music)
(Chucky screaming)
- What's the matter, Chucky?
You act like you've never
seen a dead body before.
The very last thing in this movie
is the explosive birth
of Chucky's offspring,
which leads us into the next
Chucky movie: "Seed of Chucky."
I'm not thrilled about covering that one,
but if I wanna get to Curse,
I'm gonna have to get through it.
So, check out that video on the left
and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the death bell and
select All Notifications,
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
(upbeat music)